luisa tiene nueve hormigas vamos a
escribirlo luisa
tiene nueve hormigas louis se tiene una
hormiga más que diana cuántas hormigas
tiene diana esto es lo que nos preguntan
tenemos que encontrar cuántas hormigas
tiene diana esta es nuestra pregunta
siempre es bueno cuando tenemos un
problema de este tipo preguntarnos si
diana tiene más o menos hormigas que
luisa aquí dice que luisa tiene una
hormiga más que diana así que luisa va a
tener más hormigas cuantas más una más
así que diana va a tener una hormiga
menos si luisa tiene una más que diana
entonces diana tendrá uno a menos que
luisa como escribimos una menos pues
sencillamente restamos una esto de aquí
es una menos
una menos con esto decimos que diana
tiene una menos que luisa y cuántas
tiene diana pues va a tener ocho
hormigas otra forma de hacerlo es
dibujar las hormigas que tiene luisa
aquí tenemos una hormiguita dos
hormiguitas tres hormiguitas cuatro
hormiguitas cinco hormiguitas seis
hormiguitas siete hormiguitas ocho
hormiguitas y nueve hormiguitas vamos a
tratar de ponerles las patitas aunque
son muchas
muy bien aquí está
entonces cuántas hormigas tiene diana
tiene una menos que luisa
así que quitamos una de las hormiguitas
y las hormigas que nos quedan son todas
estas cuantas son 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
hormigas hagamos otro problema que
tenemos aquí nos dicen que el peso de
una caja pequeña es 7 gramos menor que
el de una caja grande el peso de la caja
pequeña es de 6 gramos vamos a
escribirlo nos dicen que la caja
pequeña esta caja pequeña pesa 6 gramos
y nos preguntan cuál es el peso de la
caja grande así que nos preguntan de la
caja grande cuál será su peso esta es
nuestra interrogante como lo hicimos en
el problema anterior esta caja grande
tiene más peso o menos peso que la caja
pequeña y no debemos enfocarnos en el
nombre de la caja sino en lo que nos
dicen nos dicen que el peso de la caja
pequeña es 7 gramos menor que el de la
caja grande así que esta caja pequeña
pesa 7 gramos menos que la caja grande
otra forma de decir esto es que la caja
grande pesa 7 gramos más
la caja pequeña y esto nos dará el peso
de la caja grande cuál es el peso de la
caja grande pues 6 + 7 es igual a 13 y
con esto terminamos